झाल नमस्कार आपका स्वागत है जर्मन सीखिए
हिंदी में के अगले एपिसोड में पिछली बार
हमने सीखा जर्मन अल्फाबेट्स आज हम सिर्फ
18 में शब्द सीखेंगे और सारे जर्मन नंबर
सीखेंगे
शब्द शुरू करेंगे तो जैसा हमने कहा हम
सिर्फ 18 नहीं शब्द सीखने वाले हैं तो
उसमें से जो पहले 13 सकते हैं वह हम एक
साल सीखेंगे वह हम अभी सीखेंगे तो सबसे
पहले हैं 0 यानि 0इस नुरूल अभी देखिए हमने
लास्ट एपिसोड में बुरा था एक बार घुमाया
तो उसका उपचार हमेशा ही होगा नहीं होगा
नूल उसके बाद लाइंस
कि सुहाए दरारें फीवर चुन्नु
ए वैक्स
ए रिवर आफ नाइन ट्रेन वैल्यू सॉइल
मैं अभी फिर से एक बार हम देखते हैं
थे लाइंस एस वाय ड्राई फ्रूट सिम
इस समय
कि वीरवार no7 ग्लैड सॉइल अभी हमने तो
बोला था कि हम सिर्फ 18 और सीखेंगे और
सारे नंबर आएंगे पर हमने आलरेडी उनको
सिर्फ तेरा ही नंबर आते हैं तो फिर आगे
कैसे पर आकर यह बहुत आसान कैसे हम देखते
हैं अभी से 1919 में उनको होते हैं और आप
सिर्फ लगाते उससे भी लो 10 से 14 से सिर्फ
हो जाता है वह
युक्त नहीं है आप फिर 90 तो आप देखेंगे तो
13 से 19 में हमने कुछ नहीं सीखा सिर्फ
फेंस लगाते गए आपको 13 से 19 फ्री मिल गए
अब 14वां नया वर्ड सीखेंगे मुंह पर जुआ भी
मुद्दे के समाधान से जैसा हम लास्ट टाइम
बोला था कुछ एरियाज है उसको ज्वाइन
एडिक्टिव बोला जाता है पर हम हॉप ट्रिक्स
सीख रहे हैं इसलिए हम बोलेंगे इस वंश की
ओके तो हमने सीखा जो नैक अभी हमको एक से
20 आता है अब हम सीखेंगे तीस चालीस पचास
साठ सत्तर अस्सी नब्बे तुमको इंग्लिश में
कैसे किया था याद कीजिए 3040 लिए 1516
आपने एंड में पी लगा जहन में हम एंड में
ज्यादा ईजी विद लगाएंगी क्या लगाएंगे
जड़ाए
पिंप प्रगतिवाद आए हैं तो 30 है ड्राई फिश
चार अगर क्लियर है तो 40 हैपियर जिस फिल्म
जूस अग्रेंज विशाख विशिष्ट नाइन जिससे अगर
30 से नंबर तो आपको मिल गए
अच्छा ठीक है और अब हम तीन नए वर्ड्स
सीखेंगे है नेट उन्हें ज़ूलॉजिकल है राइट
टाउन एंड स्टूडेंट्स थ्रू से ज़ोर
बिल्लियों मिली ओन मतलब मिलियन तरफ हिंदी
की तरह लाख का संकट चैनल में नहीं होता है
सारे यूरोपीयन लैंग्वेजेस नहीं हो
ए क्लियर है सबको हौंडा ताऊ जजमेंट मिलियन
तो अभी देखो हमको क्या क्या आता है थोड़ा
ये हमको एक से 20 आता है हमको 30 40 50 60
70 80 90 अ हम को सौंपता है हमको हजार आता
है हमको मिले हो जाता है हमको क्या नहीं
आता हमको नहीं आ 21 22 23 24 राइड और यहां
पर फिर से हम को हमारी हिंदी कहानी
क्योंकि अगर आप देखोगे 21 22 23 को
इंग्लिश में क्या बोलते हैं तो 13 तो यहां
पर आप देखोगे तो पहले दशम स्थान आता है
2030 और फिर एकदम स्थान तो ऐसे जरा हिंदी
में देखो तो आप कैसे करते हैं 21 22 23
है तो पहले आपने क्या लिया कि किस पहले
एकदम स्थान लिया है
मैं हिंदी में जर्मन में भी ऐसे ही करना
पर कम से कम हिंदी में आपने उसका सन्नी तो
बनाया एक इस बनाया 22 बनाया जहां तो उससे
भी इस है जर्मन होती है एक और भी आई एम
कुंठित कुंड ए कुंड मतलब और 120 जनमत
को लाइक ए
कि एक और बी-2 और 20 320 ऐसे हम जाएंगे आई
कुनै न कुनै न कुनै न कुनै न कुनै न कुनै
न कुनै न कुनै नाइन कुंठित और दृढ हो गया
समझ में आया तो इस स्थिति से कम सिंपल है
वैसे अगर आपको 31 तो कैसे एक और एक और चीज
3102 समझ में अब तक ही निवास करते हैं
10 से 12 तक तो हमको पढ़ना ही पड़ेगा उसको
कुछ नहीं कर सकते नार्मल धनु सराय ड्राई
फ्रूट व अफिम जैसे कि सर्वर आ 90 अ
मैं तेरा से 19 हमने क्या किया सिर्फ
पढ़ने में ध्यान लगाया तरह इस अश्लील कि
नया वर्ष का स्वर्णिम अतीत से के लिए हमने
30 लगा रेड्डी किसी और इसे इस तरह से और
जो दो-तीन एग्जांपल लेते हैं तो आपको सबसे
पहले 4545 डाइरैक्टली करने जाओगे ना तो
उल्टा करोगे तो क्या हमारी हिंदी तो हिंदी
में क्या होता है 45 मतलब 54002
कि संजय दत्त
कि विज्ञान विज्ञान उन्हें गए और 90 आई एम
एन एक्स प्लेयर अभी सब्सक्राइब 0 उसके बाद
तो थिस सिंपल हो जाती है एक बार और 99 जाओ
तो आप उसको सिर्फ जोड़ रहे हैं फॉर
एग्जांपल अगर आपको बोलना है 2222 2222 तो
आप क्या कर रहे हो दो अलग-अलग बातें करते
हो आप 200 करोड़ सिंपल है एक बार को 100
तक ना तो आपको सिर्फ जो भी उसके बाद जो भी
संख्या में बहुत सिंपल सबको
अब समझ में आई
कि अगर आपको इसकी रिवीजन करने तो मैं आपको
एक बहुत आसान ट्रिक बताता हूं अगर आप वो
ट्रिक आसमां होंगे तो दो दिन में आपको
सारी जर्मन संखिया जाएंगी तो वह क्या है
तो जानवर में घड़ी को बोलते हैं और वहां
पैर ओर और आप टाइम कैसे वजह बताते हो 9:30
तो 9:30 9:30 तो जर्मन में कैसे बना वह
बताओगे पहले घंटे फिर वह लोग या फिर मिनट
दावा ऑयल व धराई से नौ और डेविड अगर 10:45
हुए हैं तो 3000 के पास आ जाए टाइम बताओ
जब पूरे दिन में जब Bigg Boss ने अपना
टाइम बता दो
कि 01:36 हुए आइए और ब्लैकनेस ऐसे आपसे दो
दिन करोगे आपको सारे जर्मन नंबर आने
लगेंगे ठीक है तो एक बहुत ही रिव्यू लेते
हैं और आज हम आजकल दिन सबमिट करते हैं तो
जैसे हमने सीखा जीरो से 12 हम याद करना
पड़ेगा ऑनलाइनवायग्रा ए केयरफुल इन थे
गिवन आप नाइन सैड सॉन्ग 1319 लगाओ क्रश
लगा देना मुझे नया वर्ष का झंझट फिर 3 से
90 क्या करोगे जिस लगाओ गिद्ध राजधानी
सब्जेक्ट ना इंच तीन नए वर्ड्स उन्हें
ज़ूम और 21 22 23 24 हिंदी की तरह एक और
चीज तो और भी तीनों पीस अनुसंधान एवं जिला
एवं सेशन जज और जब बड़ी संख्या होती हैं
तो वह अपनी पर हम तोड़ते हैं 3333
और दृढ टर्म्स एंड ड्राई सुंदर ड्राइवर
ब्रिटिश मुझे आशा है कि आप सबको जर्मन
नंबर से कम आसानी से समझ में आए होंगे
नेक्स्ट पाठ में हम देखेंगे दो सबसे
इंपोर्टेंट वर्क्स टो हैव तू भी और अपनी
इंट्रोडक्शन देना तो मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट
एपिसोड में धन्यवाद
हुआ था